I got an email from a guy went to high
school with right email said Kev it's
time for you to get yours I open up the
email it's two pictures in the email one
picture was a real little man standing
next to a doctor he was angry
next picture that same little man was
taller than a doctor he was giving a
thumbs up
bottom of the email said cat it's time
for you to get yours
I'm confused what the is going on
I call him yo I got your email what the
are you talking about what are you
trying to say so what do you mean what
am I trying to say so exactly what I
said what is this what are you trying to
say he said they're giving out height go
get you some
what the you mean they giving out
height exactly what I said they're
giving out hype they're taking the fat
out of people back put it in their knees
[Applause]
they're taking the fat out of people's
backs put it in their knee
he said go get rid of your back fat get
yourself some inches
I said I will do no such thing
get rid of my goddamn back fat
43 years old
I've been five five my whole life five
four five two and a half my whole
life
I have to do no like that
you gotta remember I ain't been on tour
in like four years I can't just walk out
this six six and I say about
it
I just walk out when I went over there
whatever
what's going on
what the is going on with you
look at this goddamn knees what he do to
his knees why you got all them hoes in
his back what the he do to his back
you know what I want
I want people to start thinking
through I want to get back to the times
where people had patience you got to
slow down start thinking through
stop acting on impulse let's say I go
get the procedure I come out of it with
these new knees and these long ass
ladies I'm six six look at my
knees in these long ass legs
but I still got the same arms I didn't
do
to my arms
I didn't judge it right now I can't put
my hands in my pocket cause I didn't
up
not this looking like a T-Rex
touching my chest all the time
I can't always rub in his chest
cause I misjudged it I can't get my
hands in my pocket
you gotta think through let's say I
go get the procedure I got these goddamn
new knees long ass legs my frame
look at my chest and my shoulders I'm
six six but I still wear a size seven
sneaker I didn't do to my feet
now I can't support the new body my
balance is off
I look like that that thing to be at the
car dealership instead man
that air man look at me
you gotta think through
stop acting on impulse
[Music]